bonsoir ici pierre lapointe bienvenue au
premier gala de l'adisq vers la pointe
vous avez animé le premier gala de
l'adisq mercredi soir dernier ça va être
heureux diffusé à 18 heures dimanche
avant le gala de l'adisq vous avez
beaucoup insisté cette année sur la
relève c'est important pour vous
pourquoi très tôt dans les réunions avec
l'équipe de la disco mon nom j'ai juste
dit mais si j'étais un nouvel artiste
qui sort son premier album en pandémie
ce serait la fin du monde donc j'ai
juste amené l'idée ce serait bien si on
choisissait quelques artistes établis
qui parrainait des artistes qui viennent
de sortir leur premier album qui
commence en ce moment et j'ai lancé ce
comme cela dit ce que récupérer l'idée
et ils ont décidé d'en faire une espèce
de but ultime de l'adisq cette année en
2019 vous y êtes allé avec un coup de
gueule sur les géants du web il faut
marteler au gouvernement qu'on veut que
ces grandes compagnies
la création de nouveaux plus canadien à
l'avant mais votre page suivante en
nomination pour le grand gala de
dimanche soir si vous gagnez qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire ce que vous avez
commencé parce que je pense que cette
année ce n'est pas le temps de faire des
coups de gueule d'ailleurs j'ai laissé
le dossier tous les dossiers que pouvait
être un peu épineux entendre par des me
pour moi ce n'est pas le temps je pense
que les politiques
avec d'autres choses à faire quand je
parle j'ai souvent la bête spontanée
mais c'est très étudié je connais bien
mon dos si j'écris pas mais les discours
j'écris parce que je dis et il ya eu des
discussions autour avec des gens aussi
pour pour être certain de le faire au
bon moment avec les bons arguments
j'essaie de le faire le plus rarement
possible j'attends le bon moment pour
paul n'ont pu brûler ma parole à tous
vents comment choisissez-vous vos
combats parce qu'en 2008 vous avez
participé à urgences homophobie à
l'achat récent de l'amour je vais
vraiment parce que on s'est qualifié à
l'époque des réseaux sociaux s'appelle
difficile donc pourquoi décident
participer à ça puis comment faites vos
choix faut seulement que ça me concerne
depuis que je sens que je peux défendre
un sujet sans limite et sans vote
bon la lutte contre l'homophobie c'est
sûr que ça me touche
la fondation émergence qui me donnait un
prix qui m'a vraiment ému le printemps
dernier
pour finalement seulement avoir été moi
même ce qu'il fait tranche même temps ce
qui veut dire beaucoup quand on fait
partie de la communauté gbt qu plus je
reste sensible à tout ce qui sort de la
norme qui en souffrent
[Musique]
je soutiens anniversaire il ya pas loin
de 20 ans je vais remporter le festival
de la chanson de granby ça change
évidemment votre vie ouais là nous tous
un peu quand même je ne sais pas mettre
la mienne ça change avec le recul
comment voyez ce qui s'est passé à
endesa a été
extraordinaire à l'époque je ne voulais
pas faire de chansons j'étais allé là un
peu parce que ça avait l'air de vouloir
fonctionner ou je sais pas j'avais
soumis mes chansons et pillé j'avais
écrit quatre chansons moment où j'ai
remporté granby j'étais très très
bouleversée je voulais être metteur en
scène je lai directeur artistique je
voulais être acteur je voulais monter
des spectacles faire des installations
étrange j'étais étudiant dans visual à
l'époque à l'uqam ici à montréal
et c'est comme si la vie m'avait dit que
pour faire tout ce que tu veux en
passant par la chanson et je trouve que
le médium de la chanson c'est un médium
extraordinaire parce qu'on peut se
permettre d'être un pied dans l'avant
garder un pied dans la pop pure et dure
chaque arbre et un moule
autre anniversaire 15 ans de la forêt
des mal aimés je me suis très bien de la
première écoute ce qui s'est passé dans
ma tête où j'étais quand on vit avec un
aussi gros disques dans ses valises ben
c'est déjà subi ce qui est des gens qui
font toute une carrière sans avoir un
album qui marque les esprits au tex
c'est drôle parce que ça va ça fait 15
ans mais moi je les écoute plus d'albums
la difficulté à l'écouté parce qu'il
chaussait les choix que j'ai fait à
l'époque avec lesquels j'étais en face à
l'époque qu'aujourd'hui j'ai auprès
j'aurais peut-être pas fait ça comme ça
maintenant c'est une grande fierté parce
que je sais qu'il habite encore le
quotidien plusieurs personnes et qui
risquent d'habiter de tricherie champ
car longtemps
c'est une grande fierté et c'est drôle
parce que j'ai fait plein de trucs
depuis souvent les gens parlent de cet
album là alors que j'en ai sorti depuis
quinze années au moins et puis mais ça
me rend quand même heureux parce que
y'a des gens qui vivent même posté une
fois dans leur vie en terminant pierre
lapointe après votre triomphe il ya un
an et demi à l'usiné avec votre tournée
des jouets l'ennui qui a été arrêté à
kauda pandémie vous reprenez la route
j'ai hâte de vous revoir merci pour
cette entrevue merci à toi qui m'a mis
là
vois tu as pris